Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Buon pomeriggio, buon pomeriggio a tutti.
Certo, dopo una presentazione così,
un giornalista vero,
presentarmi con uno scolapasta...
Togliamo la facciona, che è meglio.
Allora, io sono qua
per parlarvi di imprenditoria,
di grande imprenditoria globale,
mondiale, trasnazionale.
Non farò una televendita
di pentole, state tranquilli.
Però questo aggeggio, lo scolapasta,
ci servirà tra pochissimo.
Intanto, lo appoggio qua.
Allora, vi dicevo: imprenditoria globale,
transnazionale, con solide radici locali.
Se volete muovervi
da un punto A a un punto B nel mondo,
c'è l'azienda giusta che fa per voi.
Questa azienda si occupa di viaggi,
è la più grande agenzia
di viaggi del mondo.
E si occupa di voi
soprattutto se voi non avete diritto
a entrare... in Europa, per esempio.
E quindi da Kabul a Vancouver,
da Asmara fino a Roma,
da Damasco fino a Berlino
e poi fino a Goteborg,
c'è un'azienda che farà per voi.
E questa azienda si chiama
la Trafficanti Inc.
Qui ci starebbe una sigla, però vabbè.
O Trafficanti S.p.a. , se volete.
Allora, facciamo un esempio:
poniamo che stiate scappando
da Homs, in Siria,
perché vi stanno cadendo
le bombe sulla testa.
Abbiamo il pacchetto giusto per voi.
Avete pochi dollari in tasca?
Non c'è problema!
Il viaggio sarà un pochino lungo
e un pochino pericoloso,
però arriverete in Europa.
Avete qualche soldino in più in tasca,
e fuggite da una remota
zona rurale del Ghana,
volete assolutamente arrivare in Puglia
dove raccoglierete pomodori
12 ore al giorno per $5 al giorno?
Abbiamo il pacchetto che fa per voi:
attraverserete il deserto,
vi imbarcherete in Libia
e sarete in Italia.
Avete 10, 20, 30.000 euro a disposizione?
Abbiamo il pacchetto Business Class:
arriverete in aereo,
con un passaporto contraffatto.
Abbiamo già provveduto
a oliare i meccanismi,
a corrompere le guardie di frontiera
e magari l'ambasciatore o il console
per farvi rilasciare il visto.
Questa azienda opera
un po' in tutto il mondo,
ma io vorrei occuparmi
soprattutto del Mediterraneo.
Allora, dove sono i trafficanti?
E chi sono, i trafficanti?
Non sono gli scafisti!
Ogni tanto, il Ministero dell'Interno
fa conferenze stampa
roboanti in cui dice:
“Abbiamo arrestato 900 scafisti!”
Se fosse una pièce teatrale,
qualcuno di voi lì in fondo
dovrebbe dire:
“E chi se ne frega?”
Se voi arrestate un piccolo spacciatore
di droga, all'angolo della strada,
cosa succede il giorno dopo?
Ce n'è un altro.
La stessa cosa accade con gli scafisti.
I signori delle frontiere,
i trafficanti di uomini,
stanno al sicuro, stanno nelle retrovie.
Sono manager in doppiopetto,
non stanno lì sui barconi.
Stanno ad Addis Abeba,
stanno a Istanbul,
stanno a Islamabad, stanno a Bamako.
E hanno business,
magari regolari, di copertura
o che affiancano il business criminale.
Possono avere compagnie
marittime di navigazione,
possono avere flotte di pescherecci,
agenzie di viaggi a tutti gli effetti.
Possono essere poliziotti!
I signori delle frontiere
operano non in front line,
non si sporcano le mani.
Fanno sporcare le mani agli scafisti,
che sono i pesci piccoli.
Sapete chi è lui?
No, lui è stato
il primo scafista della Storia!
(Risate e Applausi)
Be', questa cosa un po' empia
e blasfema non l'ho detta io.
L’ha detta Alexander,
che è uno scafista siberiano
che ho incontrato in carcere
alcuni anni fa.
Alexander, da dietro le sbarre,
mi ha guardato negli occhi
e mi ha detto, non li fermerete mai.
Non fermerete mai i migranti,
non fermerete mai i trafficanti.
E sapete perché?
Perché Mosè è stato
il primo scafista della storia.
E io sono come Mosè.
Boom.
Alexander, scafista siberiano,
diplomato alla scuola di vela
di Vladivostok, appunto in Siberia,
lavorava per un trafficante
di nome Mohammar Kuchuk.
Mohammar Kuchuk è un grande
imprenditore del crimine:
è un talento, è un genio.
Ha tirato fuori dal coniglio
un cilindro pazzesco.
È il contrario, scusate:
dal cilindro, un coniglio pazzesco.
Quella sarebbe stata
una vera magia, peraltro.
(Risate)
Allora, avete presente
i vecchi barconi della speranza,
i pescherecci sgarrupati,
quei gommoni che vediamo
partire dalla Libia
che non riescono a reggere
nemmeno un paio di ondate?
Dimenticateli.
Mohammar Kuchuk si è inventato
gli yacht di lusso.
Ta-dah!
Yacht di lusso di cui il Mar Egeo,
da marzo a ottobre, è pieno.
Dalla costa anatolica fino in Grecia,
e poi giù fino al Salento.
Pieno di turisti, no?
Chi non ha mai pensato, una volta,
di fare una vacanza in barca a vela?
Ecco, anche lui ci ha pensato.
Un bel giorno di una mattina
di primavera di qualche anno fa
Alexander sta guidando
uno yacht come questo.
Ha un bellissimo cappellino da skipper,
una rassicurante bandiera greca o turca,
niente di sospetto.
Ma viene fermato dal guardacosta leccese.
Perché?
Perché lo yacht era un filino basso
sulla linea di galleggiamento.
Allora lo fermano, gli dicono, documenti?
Documenti a posto.
Senti ma, chi c'è sotto coperta?
Un’allegra famiglia
di turisti americani in vacanza.
Apri!
Apre, 40 afghani.
40 afghani che venivano da Herat.
40 afghani col mal di mare, ovviamente!
Nasci in montagna, fai due settimane
di crociera nell'Egeo, è ovvio.
Ognuno di questi afghani
aveva pagato €10.000 a testa.
Quel vascello valeva €400.000.
Un'operazione geniale.
Mentre tutti pensavano
ai barconi della speranza,
lui si inventa la cosa
più mimetica possibile.
Mohammar Kuchuk di barche come queste
ne ha mandate decine, centinaia,
prima che l'autore leccesi scoprissero
questo trucco, questo inganno.
Mohammar Kuchuk ha fatto
un sacco di soldi,
milioni e milioni di euro.
Ha reinvestito, pare, parte dei proventi
comprandosi 200 ville
sulla costa anatolica.
E poi, sotto prestanome,
si dice abbia comprato
un'azienda farmaceutica.
I maligni dicono che così
produce pillole contro il mal di mare,
da dare agli afghani.
(Risate)
Allora, Kuchuk fa un sacco di soldi,
e questa è un'azienda
che fa un sacco di soldi.
Diamo un po' di numeri:
io amo, dare i numeri.
Detta così sembra un po'... però...
Secondo UNHCR,
sono arrivati l'anno scorso,
via mare, 362.753 migranti.
Ho fatto una piccola stima al ribasso:
ognuno di loro ha pagato €3.000
il costo del viaggio.
Fate i conti, un miliardo di euro
fatturati illegalmente nel Mediterraneo.
Un miliardo di euro, cash,
che non possiamo tracciare,
che finiscono anche
ad alimentare altri business,
come droga, armi,
e forse anche il terrorismo.
Non lo sappiamo, non sono tracciabili.
Quindi, tutto è ipotizzabile.
Però ho fatto una stima al ribasso,
perché pensate a chi arriva
da più lontano.
Questa è solo l'ultima tratta:
chi arriva da Kabul,
e ha dovuto attraversare a piedi
le montagne dell'Iran e poi della Turchia,
ha dovuto pagare vari trafficanti.
Questo Mediterraneo vale
miliardi di euro ogni anno.
Io vi sto raccontando il secondo business
al mondo dopo la droga.
Si dice, nel mondo, 10 miliardi
di euro di fatturato ogni anno.
Con una piccola differenza,
rispetto alla droga.
Poniamo che io stia portando
un carico di cocaina attraverso il Sahel,
e lo devo consegnare a Mokhtar Belmokhtar.
Sapete chi è Mokhtar Belmokhtar?
È un tipino: ex leader di Al Qaeda
nel Maghreb islamico,
detto Mister Marlboro Man
perché traffica in sigarette.
Detto il Guercio: ha perso un occhio
combattendo in Afghanistan.
È l'ultima persona al mondo
con cui vorrei contrarre un debito.
a cui io dovrei consegnare
il carico di cocaina
che poi ho perso nel Sahel.
Vi immaginate? Rischio altissimo!
Invece, se io perdo
un camion di migranti nel Sahel
con 180 persone
che hanno già pagato il viaggio,
la vocina lì in fondo
mi dirà: chissenefrega.
È un business a rischio zero.
La Trafficanti Inc.
funziona anche per questo,
ma per altre caratteristiche.
Ve le elenco molto brevemente.
Primo: gli attori, i trafficanti,
si parlano tra di loro.
Correva l'anno 2013.
Ero al Cairo, a Piazza Tahrir,
con ancora gli echi di quella rivoluzione:
l'abbiamo chiamata primavera araba,
diciamo un lungo autunno.
E incontro El Douli.
El Douli è un trafficante.
A El Douli, la prima domanda che faccio è:
senti, ma chi è il boss dei boss?
Chi è il più grande trafficante
nel vostro campo?
Lui mi guarda dritto
negli occhi e mi dice:
se mi fai questa domanda,
non hai capito niente.
E ho detto, be’, è un bel modo
per iniziare un'intervista, no?
Siamo tanti, ci aiutiamo,
ci facciamo favori,
collaboriamo tra noi,
ci prestiamo i soldi.
Io lavoro con i libici, per esempio;
ma anche con i sudanesi.
Allora i trafficanti
si parlano, si aiutano,
non esistono frontiere o barriere;
anzi, lavorano su quello.
Sono flessibili e veloci:
l'Europa chiude una rotta,
e loro ne aprono subito un'altra.
L'Europa ferma i barconi,
e loro si inventano gli yacht di lusso.
E offrono servizi su misura.
L’agenzia di viaggi illegale del mondo
ti offre il pacchetto su misura.
Scusate:
si parlano: comunicazione, cooperazione,
servizi su misura, flessibilità.
Sono tutte le caratteristiche
che l'Europa non mette in campo!
Cioè, l'Europa che vuole fronteggiare
il traffico di migranti,
e vuole gestire il dossier immigrazione,
non mette in campo quello
che il crimine mette in campo!
È incredibile!
La Trafficanti Inc. non è solo questo.
È anche social.
E come ogni azienda che funziona,
ha un dipartimento marketing
efficientissimo
e ha i social media manager.
Quindi usano Facebook, Instagram,
Viber e Telegram.
Non ci credete?
Eccolo qui, profilo Instagram
di un trafficante.
Ecco il sogno europeo.
Facebook: profili Facebook aperti,
dove trovate le tariffe.
Per esempio, da dove si parte,
in quanto tempo si arriverà in Europa.
I bambini sotto i 12 anni
viaggiano gratis.
Soddisfatti o rimborsati!
Non sto scherzando, è così.
Offrono pacchetti su misura
con delle promozioni marketing
tipo i 3 X 2 del supermercato.
Sono social.
Se noi avessimo monitorato attentamente
i social media e social network
a fine dicembre del 2014,
avremmo capito che qualcosa
di molto grosso stava bollendo in pentola.
Questo.
Il 31 dicembre del 2014,
è una notte buia e tempestosa.
È vero, eh, era una notte
buia e tempestosa.
E mentre a Lecce tutti
si preparano per il Capodanno,
questa nave, o meglio, un'altra nave
molto simile, Blue Sky,
sta veleggiando e punta dritto
verso Santa Maria di Leuca.
Non risponde alle segnalazioni,
non risponde alle richieste
da parte della capitaneria di porto.
Tira dritto.
Scatta l'allarme: terrorismo? Kamikaze?
Partono, si levano in volo
gli elicotteri della Marina Militare,
uomini dei corpi speciali
si calano a bordo, irrompono in cabina,
e cosa trovano?
Terroristi? No.
Esplosivo? No.
768 siriani.
Era l'inizio della più grande
e geniale operazione
di traffico di migranti
della storia recente,
a parte quella di Mosè.
In due mesi, 17 cargo come questi
sono arrivati sulle coste del Sud Italia:
5.000 migranti trasportati,
quasi tutti siriani,
quindi richiedenti asilo,
€8.000 il costo medio del biglietto,
un fatturato di 40 milioni di euro.
Mica male, eh?
Tutti con cargo a fine vita,
cargo inutilizzabile, erano ferraglia.
Questa è imprenditoria criminale
geniale e talentuosa.
A questo punto,
sorge spontanea una domanda:
chi è il più grande alleato
dei trafficanti di uomini?
Noi.
Noi, e lo scolapasta.
E finalmente...
E adesso grande Televendita,
3 x 2, l'evento...No!
Allora, quanti buchi riuscite
a tappare con due mani?
Dieci, non di più.
Ecco, questa è l'immigrazione.
Ci sono molti più buchi, qua.
Per quanto noi proviamo a tamponare,
a chiudere una rotta,
a chiudere una porta,
si apriranno finestre
e si squarceranno muri.
Non ce la possiamo fare,
il nostro approccio
è totalmente sbagliato.
Noi siamo il più grande
alleato dei trafficanti.
Noi che costruiamo i muri.
Sapete perché i muri
alimentano il business dei trafficanti?
Perché, come diceva Alexander,
non li possiamo fermare.
Noi costruiamo il muro?
La rotta si allunga,
più trafficanti coinvolti,
viaggio più pericoloso,
più soldi che vanno
ad alimentare il business criminale.
La parola chiave è vuoto.
L'Europa non c'è.
L'Europa non dà una risposta
legale alternativa
al siriano che è costretto
a spendere €10.000
per esercitare un diritto riconosciuto
dalla legge internazionale e italiana:
si chiama diritto d'asilo.
Non c'è una risposta istituzionale:
c'è un vuoto riempito dal crimine.
In questo comportamento,
l'Europa è decisamente colpevole.
Perché le ONG erano
davanti al mare libico?
Perché non c'era l’Europa!
La parola chiave, quindi, è vuoto.
Ci sono però delle soluzioni.
Vi ho un po' depressi? Sì, eh?
Le soluzioni ci sono, attenzione.
Innanzitutto, tagliamo le gambe
al business dei trafficanti.
Proponiamo delle soluzioni legali,
per esempio i corridoi umanitari.
Che ci sono, ma sono residuali:
stiamo parlando di centinaia,
migliaia di persone, sono pochissime!
Aiuti e investimenti per lo sviluppo
nei paesi di origine:
dobbiamo rendere non conveniente
partire dal Ghana,
non andare a investire
in Libia e in Niger,
come l'Italia e l'Europa stanno facendo.
Quelli sono paesi di transito.
Quello che stiamo facendo noi
è chiudere le rotte.
Tra un po' si riapriranno,
io mi ci gioco la camicia,
ci troviamo qua fra fra un anno,
se mi invitate ancora,
si sarà riaperta la rotta turca,
perché stiamo pagando per chiudere
i buchi di quello scolapasta.
Non funziona.
Cooperazione di giustizia internazionale:
è inutile che arrestiamo
i pesci piccoli, che sono gli scafisti.
Dobbiamo arrestare i boss dei boss,
che sono al sicuro,
Quindi un volenteroso
magistrato di Palermo
deve poter parlare
con un magistrato libico.
È difficilissimo.
Monitoraggio dei social:
Internet è una fonte
pazzesca di informazioni,
quindi dobbiamo stare
molto, molto attenti.
Armonizzare le norme
sull'immigrazione in Europa.
L'Europa fa un po' quello che le pare:
la Germania accoglie
un milione di siriani,
l'Ungheria fa un muro,
la Francia ce li respinge
e l'Italia non sa bene cosa fare.
Tutto questo crea opportunità
per la criminalità:
anche questo deve essere evitato.
L'effettiva riallocazione
dei migranti in tutta Europa,
e adesso ci arriviamo meglio.
E vorrei chiudere con un paio di inviti.
Il primo invito è alla categoria
di cui, ahimè,
faccio parte, i giornalisti.
I giornalisti hanno raccontato,
e continuano a raccontare
l'immigrazione con due parole:
invasione, emergenza.
Non è né l'una né l'altra.
Non è emergenza perché
l'immigrazione è strutturale.
Un terremoto è un'emergenza,
lo scoppio di una guerra è un'emergenza.
L'invasione – scusate, lapsus freudiano -
l'immigrazione esiste da 20 anni.
Gli sbarchi esistono da 20 anni.
E come diceva Alexander, continueranno.
Quindi, prendiamola
come un dato strutturale.
Invasione:
362.000 arrivi su 500 milioni
di abitanti in Europa è un'invasione?
È come se adesso,
fatte salve le proporzioni,
entrasse un gomito
e mezza caviglia di un siriano,
e voi : “L’invasione Siriana!”
No, non è un’invasione,
chiamiamo le cose col loro nome.
Quindi, cari giornalisti, stiamo ai fatti.
E poi c'è un invito alla politica.
Cara politica,
non strumentalizzare quelle cose lì
perché si vota tra sei mesi,
e parli alla pancia
e fai paura alla gente.
Se il giornalismo restituisce
la dignità dei fatti,
la politica non li può strumentalizzare.
E la politica, mentre il giornalista
deve raccontare i fatti,
io dalla politica voglio visione.
Che Italia, che Europa vogliamo
fra dieci o vent'anni?
Questo io vorrei.
Poi però c'è un invito anche per voi.
Sull'immigrazione,
come su tante altre cose,
noi tutti abbiamo il diritto
di avere un'opinione.
Abbiamo il dovere di avere
un'opinione informata.
Esigete e cercate informazione
di qualità, che c'è!
Esigetela.
Il giornale, i giornalisti, il giornalismo,
noi dovremmo essere
i cani da guardia, no?
Io spesso, troppo spesso.
vedo dei simpatici barboncini.
dei teneri bassotti
che ti portano la ciabatta,
dei chihuahua un po' urlacchianti.
Ecco, per favore:
esigete dei solidi, rabbiosi.
guardinghi cane lupo.
E in bocca al lupo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)